people that believe in themselves piss
people off
um they do piss people off
because they expose our lack of belief
in ourselves
that's a bar but they force us to deal
with that that's a bar
and it is true you see people who go i
could do this i could do whatever and
this logan paul situation i can see why
his self-belief
rubs people the wrong way but
when you see somebody do the thing that
they more or less said that they were
going to do
right it is wildly impressive and it
forces you to go oh [ __ ]
maybe anything is possible now i'm not
gonna
be delusional here okay he did not win
that fight
if there were judges he would have lost
that fight on
the cards very easily no no i think he
won
the first round i think he won he had
that big flurry didn't really touch
floyd but floyd didn't really touch him
so
i'll give him the first round maybe the
second round and then debatable
maybe after that floyd mopped him
he did land a big overhand right on
floyd that i think actually stunned
floyd
really yeah he did there was a i forget
which round it was him but it actually
he actually landed
but um what was amazing about this fight
was
is the stakes were changed where
[Music]
floyd had to stop him for floyd to win
right and logan had to survive right
for him to win right right that's it
wasn't written down
right that these were the rules but
those are the rules emotionally
and we were all going into it we were
just like listen i swear to god
i've probably even said it yo floyd is
gonna take him into deep water and then
you're gonna take him down i mean
everybody i messaged you know i was i'm
i'm literally a dm stylebender
uh yesterday before the fight i was like
what do you think is really gonna happen
he goes floyd's gonna tire him out and
then he'll just probably tko and they'll
stop the fight late in the fight
i thought that was gonna happen and it
didn't happen
and floyd tried and i know a lot of
people are like oh he was holding him
blah blah blah
a lot of people tried holding floyd they
weren't 200 pounds but now you're
bringing up 200 pounds
i was absolutely astonished when i saw
twitter start
capping everybody on twitter was talking
about i mean you even saw
jesus and mero who said that you know
floyd was going to catch a body tonight
switch and be like well that's kind of
floyd's fight they did a [ __ ]
phenomenal job though
they were great absolutely
uh but they initially there was yo
floyd's catching a body he's gonna take
him down is over
and then that turned into listen that's
what floyd does the guy's much bigger
and everybody starts making these
excuses for floyd charlemagne
is sending our group text after saying
floyd's going to get him out of here on
the podcast someone was 100
certain goes yo that's what floyd does i
mean he was going to win a decision
ain't nobody paid for a decision
yeah people were paying money to see a
paul brother
get knocked out i think people were so
annoyed with jake
they were willing to pay to see logan
get knocked out
right and it didn't happen yeah
and that is a win for logan yeah and you
capping if you say otherwise i admit i'm
wrong i thought logan was going down
i thought logan's going down in the
fifth or sixth round yeah and i thought
they were just gonna stop the fight
the distance was too much for floyd to
cover yeah he wasn't fast enough to
cover maybe younger when he was younger
floyd he would be able to but he wasn't
and he wasn't willing to take the risk
in order to land those punches right i
thought floyd fought very conservatively
yeah he walked down there with his hands
up and he was trying to like mix it up
on the inside
but he wasn't really trying to counter
that much yeah you know it was
it was very impressive hats off to
[ __ ] now was that
floyd playing it safe because he's like
i'm just here to get paid
i think logan was right floyd had the
most to lose
yeah yeah of course of course yeah and
the guy's 200 pounds i think what
happened was in the first round
floyd was like oh god the guy's kind of
fast okay
and at 200 pounds you hit hard
yeah it just is what it is and and he
was like okay so i got to
kind of be cautious with this guy i
don't want to get caught and then look
absolutely stupid out here
and then floyd's hard to bully him he's
just he basically
let him punch himself out the first
couple rounds right that's the strategy
same thing happened with uh mcgregor
right
right let mcgregor be super active in
the first few rounds once mcgregor is
tired he won't have the same sting on
his punches
and then you just start walking him down
body shots upstairs
and floyd was trying to get him out of
there right floyd was annoyed i haven't
seen floyd annoyed in a fight since he
fought victor ortiz when victor ortiz
was head-butting him
right and remember you hit him with that
check hook when the uh ref separated him
and then just finished him yeah but
that's the last time i've seen floyd
floyd was like stop holding he was upset
floyd wanted to get logan out of there
right he was not content with just
letting the fight go
and then go to the distance he wanted to
get him out and he couldn't
right he couldn't get him out of there
no matter how hard he tried
and somehow the fight shifted
to floyd has to stop him or else he
loses
that's not the case floyd won the fight
right but he lost it
right and hats off to logan if you score
up
i mean you're the rules when you play
jason williams were actually if you
score one point you win
exactly but that's it even if if i
played brian scallobrini and it was 11-1
yeah
i won you won but how you let me score a
point dog come on
you decide these rules somehow the rules
that floyd decided actually helped logan
which in which way which rules because
there's no decision on the fight no
judges okay
so and and the actually the bigger
gloves yeah if there were smaller gloves
maybe those shots that floyd is landing
they sting a little bit more yeah
right yeah if there were smaller gloves
yeah you never know if there were judges
and they all just said
8-0 floyd or 7-1 logan yeah now logan
can't go out and say i beat him
right logan is literally going i won
jake paul's going i won
all the casual fight fans have no clue
what the [ __ ] happened all they saw is
that their guy went
eight rounds with the greatest to ever
do it and didn't really look that beat
up
yeah and it wasn't super super
conclusive
i mean it's not like i mean he was
bullying him he was laying his shots and
logan wasn't landing anything the last
six rounds
except that one big bomb but it wasn't
so abusive
that you're like oh wow he got destroyed
right
the average casual could go i guess
logan won yeah
the casual nah all right maybe not yeah
but
but you're playing with narratives now
you know now he could just go
the victory was going eight rounds
before he's like i'm gonna finish him
and now he's like i went eight rounds
with the graves of all time yeah
so it's just i it just it's really it's
really impressive
yeah it's really because now the
decision's kind of up to the court of
public opinion yes and logan is better
at manipulating the court of public
opinion than floyd 100
100 but it was amazing to see all the
cap on twitter he's a heavyweight
you know weight divisions matter which
is what logan was saying the whole
[ __ ] time and now you've got all the
floyd stands like myself
trying to make little caveats for why
floyd fought like that yeah floyd was
there to finish him and he couldn't
finish him
and that is credit to logan enough said
i disagree go i don't think
anybody thought floyd was going to drop
him
like floyd never has not that's what i
was saying
i thought he was going to pick him apart
more i thought like the
the number differences were going to be
bigger
yeah you know like he did out punch him
two to one but still
yeah i thought it was gonna be like four
to one or something he's supposed to be
five and one but
you gotta give him some credit like
logan was holding him
every time he tried to get he tried to
mix up with him sure so it's like
it's frustrating and when you do have
that much strength over him yeah he
can't break out the hold as easily as he
used to be able to yeah so it's like
yeah i don't discredit floyd he's like
he was trying to fight i give it up to
him that yo
you would going at him a bigger stronger
guy
you could have gotten knocked out but he
was attacking this is this is this is
the twitter cap
it's not cash we're talking about the
greatest of all time the greatest to
ever box in the history of boxing
according to andrew the greatest to ever
do anything like this nobody's
their thing than floyd is at boxing and
he couldn't find a way where logan
couldn't hold him
but in a specific weight class like if
he fought mike tyson what i'm saying
like if floyd fought mike tyson mike
tyson would win right well mike tyson is
a professional boxer
right well then paul started boxing
three years ago if you've been boxing
for 25 years
you should not you should be able to
find a way you're the greatest boxer in
history and not only because your
physical attributes because your mental
attributes you were finding a way
to get out of any situation you've ever
been put in
he couldn't do it father time is
undefeated
he was too slow he couldn't close the
distance and he
he he was forced to just straight up
walk him down with his gloves up because
he couldn't counter him
he was too slow to counter him there's
too much distance right right so he's
like i got to just walk straight in
when he walked straight in that's when
he was susceptible to being held
right he couldn't
he couldn't do it i don't think he
couldn't counter him because of speed he
couldn't counter him because of the just
the distance
disenchant speed right there was too
much distance to cover
that he was countering someone uh he was
landing most of his shots
he would be he would do a uh he would
open with a hook yeah
and that wasn't off the counter what he
was trying to do is hit
um logan with this pull two so logan
would throw his shot and then he would
pull back and then
shoot a right hand before logan could
throw his his right hand yeah
and that barely landed it it didn't land
that much but i'm just saying
i think it didn't land because of the
distancing like he had to get
super close just to be able to do that
counter because he's usually like
falling back when he throws it yeah so
it's like it's hard for her
yeah yeah 10 years ago floyd lands
whatever he wants
floyd lands whatever he wants i'm
telling you bro i'm telling you
he is slower now but that's to logan's
credit it was really brilliant what they
did you got to give credit
i'm taking it nobody want to give credit
to this guy i'm giving away
floyd was in there with mcgregor okay
mcgregor got his ass kicked
way more way more
than logan paul and i think way more
and i would say the difference is height
and weight
logan paul started boxing three years
ago yes but if a guy 50 pounds heavier
than you
grabs you i don't care how good of a
boxer you are
all i'm saying is this is now the
discussion like everybody's making
logan's argument when everybody was
throwing that [ __ ] away
before yesterday before yesterday logan
was like there wait divisions in boxing
for a reason and i'm going to show you
why and everybody's like shut up you're
going to get your ass chopped down i'm
talking about like
professional everybody asks well that's
what i would ask you you'd be like and i
think we said if he lands one
maybe al said it he lands one he could
hurt him and you were like there's oh
you're talking about a one in a million
chance yeah that he lands one yeah
um i went on stage right when the fight
started then flew here so i'm taking
your word for it but i don't
i'm not super shocked by that outcome
and to your point about conor
connor didn't box three years straight i
know conor boxes well
but he's an mma guy could you say logan
paul
just boxed four three years straight in
that way aside from being bigger and
more reach and more
weight no he is a better boxer than
connor and just
skill and dedication no because your
boxing as
part of your preparation for your fight
so he'd been doing that since he was a
kid connor
right logan has it we're talking about
three years of boxing experience all i'm
trying to say is the conversation has
shifted and logan shipped the
conversation yes the conversation before
was
he's going to walk him down i ask any
professional asks anybody in the
industry ask anybody at all same
same perspective it was uh floyd's going
to walk him down
and then in the later rounds he's just
going to start piece him up same way he
did to connor get the tko right
couldn't do it and now everybody's like
it's because of the weight differential
and that's what logan said the whole
time and everybody was like man get the
[ __ ] out of here you don't got a chance
i said it's his face on a podcast i go
you don't got a [ __ ] chance yeah
and he didn't win but he didn't get
taken
people say that his face yeah and i'm
sure that is motivating
yeah and what i found just is like the
self-belief thing i remember
before the fight he tweeted something
like every day when i moved to l.a
uh every morning and every night i would
look in the mirror and say you're gonna
be the most famous person in the world
one day yeah
and he's like and now it's on its way to
happening and you can argue with that
but i i was like yo that [ __ ] works
the people who have that self-belief not
every one of them gets
super famous but i bet you every super
famous person
does that [ __ ] and has that self-belief
so i looked at that as inspiring
yeah you can hate that if you want to or
you could just emulate it
and see where it gets you that's the gps
self-belief is a gps
yeah if you don't have that [ __ ] you go
nowhere right now just because you have
it doesn't mean you're going to put in
the hard work a lot of [ __ ]
ain't going to move to puerto rico and
dedicate three years of their life to
doing a [ __ ]
becoming a boxer overcome or whatever
the hell you want to do but that is the
gps
right you also need to know the address
in order to get there and what things
you have to do in order to get there but
it's a foundation if you do not believe
in yourself you're not going nowhere
right simple as that it was just [ __ ]
impressive to see man
yeah it was just so impressive now floyd
put out on instagram like a month ago he
was like yo i'm gonna fight logan paul
in an exhibition
and if jake paul can get through his
opponent then i'll fight jake paul in an
exhibition floyd said he's not fighting
anymore
no at the press conference do you think
that like what did this fight change his
perspective
yeah logan retired floyd again that's
what people don't realize like
yo it's facts like you could say
whatever you want but
floyd said in the post-fight presser he
went from before this fight he goes
you know what uh yeah i'll fight jake
could get it afterwards we'll fight the
both of them matter of fact i'll fight
the both of them the same night
so afterwards i don't think i'm doing
any of these exhibitions anymore i've
made a billion dollars in all my fight
purses everything's good we out of here
yeah i think if he started to interrupt
but if he takes care of of logan in two
rounds
you you don't think he's fighting jake
after two
yeah he didn't like the way the sentence
was worded even though logically is
correct
what really the reality is uh floyd
realized he's old
probably yeah and so he's like all right
i need to retire because this is [ __ ]
embarrassing
yep yeah but the guy did it you know
what i mean the guy hung in there
and he made you realize you're old oh oh
if you played a retired nba player and
he was like bro i'll kick the [ __ ] out
of any young kid whatever
and then he beat you but he was like
yeah i can't play these young kids
anymore
you you wouldn't be like i [ __ ] won
dog yeah i'm not [ __ ] yeah but i
wouldn't
i wouldn't claim i retired him you
retired him
like that son i know it's crazy to say
you have to understand this hurts me
that's my favorite athlete ever
i love floyd maybe i'm the biggest floyd
mayweather apologist when the whole
world was hating on floyd mayweather
because he was floyd money mayweather
and doing all this flashy [ __ ] and
beating the [ __ ] out of all these
fighters that people actually really
loved
i love floyd yeah the whole [ __ ] time
purest boxer i've ever seen in my entire
life
yeah it pains me to see what i saw
was jordan on the wizards say what
jordan on the wizards it was jordan on
the wizard he still hadn't
still had it you still had a jumper
buddy but it just wasn't there
it just wasn't there and yes there was a
weight differential but fully was so
good it didn't [ __ ] matter
it didn't matter but why didn't you say
that conor retired floyd
after floyd b connor like why wasn't
that when he was like
because isn't that when floyd was like
all right i'm done like i'm retiring and
then he came out of retirement to fight
logan well then he got his 50-0 with
conor so i think that's what we all
again i'm very casual but i i always
thought he's gonna try to get to 50-0
because nobody's gotten that
and once he got that and won and made
100 million dollars
and he actually stopped him and won he's
like all right i'm going to retire i've
accomplished everything i will
accomplish
with logan he said i'm 44. it's just
good to know i can hang with these young
kids
he's not a pro boxer he's a pro youtuber
yeah
and for you to be like i i can't fight
anymore that you realize i'm
never in my life i'm done did i think i
was going to say floyd mayweather
barely beat a podcaster
[Laughter]
i can't believe i just said that
sentence floyd mayweather he
barely lost two rounds to a podcast how
about this now
never did you think you would say yeah
unbelievable yeah yeah
never did i think in my life i would say
that floyd mayweather
got hit with a one-two clean by a
podcaster
floyd mayweather didn't get hit by a
one-two by some of the best boxers in
the history of the sport
he got hit by a 1-2 by a podcaster by a
youtuber
by a guy who would go around the world
doing splits
that's that's what he would do he would
do splits around the world
splits he'd jump in there and do [ __ ]
splits
and he landed a one-two literally what
george jenko said he was gonna do and we
were like george get the [ __ ] out of
here he did
it the exact [ __ ] punch that we told
george janko he's a maniac for saying
he's going to land a one-two
george ago is in the green room and
[ __ ] in phoenix and tells us
now we got a crazy punch what he's gonna
do is he's gonna throw a jab
and then throw a right hand afterwards
i'm like [ __ ] did you say he's
gonna land a one two
one and he did
[Applause]
unbelievable
you